Gleason's coming by the way definitely
there's Laxus
vodka oh that was a cop itself I would
have followed that black car back
someday thing I'm not sure not anymore
macro way I'm bummed doesn't kind of
come but well I left my phone is like a
visible a taxi with clarity husband like
my name is Gary Thomas I've been telling
you
accountants of equity I'm triple-a given
a pedigree Sabine enough less oh my
faculties are putting the works and I'm
jernard the moving furniture eleven
[Music]
cities like New York Hartford and
Providence are all expected to get
between 12 to 18 inches of snow Boston
and Philadelphia
Chrissy up to a foot and some other
areas could get more than two feet
[Music]
can you catch one of like wanting nobody
so many many more there's not a flight
out of New York
yes one that you don't get the benefits
unless you move got a blizzard coming in
and then switch up someplace Jordans
flights are canceled be rocks who knows
where I am from Syria now we're going to
some kind of higher level circle stuff
that is big that helps a lot of times we
get stuck in like the day-to-day
calendar and there's a lot of meetings
that don't allow us to quickly make
macro like two hours with the leadership
team happen he says in order to do that
that's canceling if you've got 850
minute movie system like that kind of
letting those cool down so what's on my
fiction tent Blizzard inclined to accept
with our CFO was decided within 10
minutes was deployed specially at the
last two first-class ports out in New
York City tonight
booked the hotel he just spent five
hours tomorrow with the CFO all on a
whim it was actually useful being often
chosen 42 in often menus in New York so
pedophilia New York which was fantastic
with an act on are canceled now to do
more than that in between those times
issue about I plan to set up with Rafael
venerable day together to accomplish
week and the Khmer nutritionist of
Wednesday
she's only students Thursday back
holding us
the your Saturday for the iPhone then is
doing a week which so I'll adjust
whipped up that is just getting better
at it which helps it's also again you
guys you a sorcerer cooking last white
like simply went home it's funny growing
out for you can think about booking like
a flight and like going on like a
vacation with your family take this big
like process of like okay we're going to
like poke the flight now I look quite
like in my sleep and so that paint idea
of like sitting by like Donnelly and I
was a real so I can here just quickly
Kingdom do yes I think it just you know
you're young dude how are you yeah I
mean I think it's going to a band flow
you know I think it if you know this
place is going to be the containing
rocket ship that it is there may be some
real opportunities for you and work I
think that you get to a place where like
[ __ ] man I just need to do [ __ ] for
myself here's the good news
missile this office is open for you if
you want to grow here or if you want
support or strategy to win outside of
here I think there is no advise it's
hard to bounce both you got a reverse
engineer your mindset of like where
you're at and your world's going to
change so many things happen between 28
and 35 in a man and woman's life I think
you need to just think about how you
want it to play out you know there's no
wrong right you've got plenty of time
things will change
I mean you want a family where do you
want to live these are things that
really start to manifest I think the one
I will give you one big piece of life I
do think the economy's can't stay great
forever and I do think that that's
something you have to factor in if
you're going to go with more high-risk
and do it all by yourself
or reverse I mean I don't know you know
veiners going to do better than others
but like I think I mean the amount of
agency people are going to be looking
for jobs in two or three years when she
hits the fan you know so I don't know
the good news is you can come and have
any conversation with me
there's anything I can answer for you
let's see I'm sure like you get at all
type of intriguing question isn't
glorify coming you know I just want to
answer the answer the questions people
have you know like I'm not looking for
something clever I'm looking for truth
you know me my friends are predicates
like we've been talking up as a lot of
these are like in artist one he's
starting to evaluate our passions in the
validity of our past and this question
like what is it that makes you forget
the [ __ ] being a businessman like I've
got it I've always had it like running
my businesses like I don't even eat
can't [ __ ] if you didn't eat do you know
what I mean so I got it real good so I
that's what stops me will go into the
bathroom the games like I mean like you
know it's crazy
I do the blog but it's edited so giver
like whoa you never eat or anything and
then people will read comments like but
it's the way it's edited but like Tyler
d-roc know like I don't and like I don't
do anything like it's I'm a robot
because I'm so passionate like my work
my work you know that's what I wish for
everybody
[Music]
ready ready yeah I gotta just go sorry
three two one go actually this is a
pretty impressive resume but you know
many degrees
yeah actually I see with them two
degrees huh you're hired
[Music]
planetary illusion real poisonous
all right look one okay
[Music]
want me to go YouTube live for this
episode we're Wi-Fi
yeah I know okay yeah should write
because we got Wi-Fi little too hard
yeah there we go shot is pulling around
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 2 44 of the ask gary vee
show hey Taylor its Gary jr. on the
askgaryvee show no way yes well okay how
do you get over the stump of you're
graduating and you feel this pressure
because you're trying to feel something
but you're still so young but you want
to do the staff grow at bay and I'm just
in a rut you need to be patient as [ __ ]
Taylor you're you're 20 to 23 years old
like what do you think is going to
happen overnight
yeah now so you need to be fast 7:00
a.m. to 2:00 in the morning every day
but in the big picture you need to
realize nothing good is going to happen
for next six years every second you
spend thinking about what somebody else
has is taking away from time that you
could create something for yourself yeah
you're losing you're losing because
you're laying in your bed looking at
somebody's [ __ ] glamorous
photoshopped picture of them doing
something cool and you're envious and
you're jealous and you're impatient and
it's crippling you're up side yeah
because that's where I want to be and I
know I'm not there yet
you've been don't [ __ ] I know so big
this [ __ ] that actually gets you there
so that you earn it instead of like
dwelling that you're not there and
hoping something's going to happen I
don't know what's going through your
mind
yeah well I guess I'm house growing on
the sides I don't think I'm doing enough
I guess you've got to deploy patient and
you've got to love the process I'm
addicted to the process of the battle
scars the step back need to stop giving
a [ __ ] about what anybody else has and
realize that if you put your head down
and just work for the next 10 years no
glamour no new [ __ ] car you taste
jewelry quick event no Coachella the
[ __ ] new [ __ ] you go to [ __ ]
work you will have it and every time you
clear that only things I just mentioned
it would slow down your property look
that's the answer to all these questions
now that alone things do stuff kind of
self [ __ ] we're kind of a plumbing work
all right I will I'm going to give you
the best piece of ice I got dr. suburbs
are super complicated and I think it's
but I think it's actually right you need
to more than anything think about two
core things in my opinion and it's awful
very little context we need to get to
know each other better yet one you have
to at all costs not beat yourself up
with yourself yes at all ha fair enough
it's huge it's to edit our forever
it's yesh you need to really be your own
biggest fan
instead of critiquing everything yes I'm
every right to go downstairs in ten
minutes I need to see Roger I need to
bang them all out I want to do business
right
what time's the flight they identify
very configure now unhappy and she's
gonna be mad
we're talking insane
Stu is so talented right we need to hang
this best painting ever no man Franco
appreciate it look at the blue eyes look
at your name is blue eyes yeah yeah it's
huge or comparing yourself oh yeah
because you don't know their truth by
the way you don't know what's under the
hood it looks the part people can tell
you at the [ __ ] that means
wine-tasting on Saturday discards it was
actually happening but it's not great
the understand has important but evil
number two what course number two moment
in time music I've got to wrap your head
around how young you actually are which
scene is seemingly different when you're
kids a little bit you have to wrap your
head around how early in the process
this is and how this is just a very
small moment in time yeah how we build
the social following and how we see us
and people from my team and and I think
both would be smart depending on how
this flushes out after whether you know
you're not doing anything with a
business partner short term or whether
you are and then how to incorporate into
that very quickly I can tell you you
need to get every voice out of your head
besides yourself and
you'll win no you will if you just
accept yourself with me it looks like an
initial coming by us but it doesn't feel
like that it's a consumer my content
because I just don't have any time for
it like what you gonna beat yourself up
can't live your life based on other
people's point of view
[Music]
what's internal timing no holy [ __ ]
we're going to miss this flight and if
we do we're finished
oh [ __ ]
7:14 that's really bad man that's really
[ __ ] bad
what is it terms of rock rock man that
one deep yeah Gliese is coming by the
way step one go there's max
bhakta
oh that was a cop itself I would have
followed that black card back today I
think I'm not around anymore javi what's
the number now
[Music]
good less than a huge accident huh
what's it say now right Thank You Man
but I pumped about that pissed I'm going
to miss a flight and I'm going to lose
out on like 130 thousand dollars and
speaking it closes at 7:45 Debbie please
do Cantona
7:26 because the flight sim 55 chemical
limiting all cost everybody else's paper
and everything
usual numbers compositions because it
seems a feel-good laid out for them
reading from now that goes away this is
real [ __ ] this is how you happy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]